que ce soit ici ou à l'étranger elle m'a
dit jamali et sabrine german projetait
de commettre un attentat
la menace était si sérieuse que la soeur
de l'un d'eux a prévenu la police
elle dit avoir entendu ceci si on ne
peut pas aller là bas on va le faire ici
les policiers de la gendarmerie royale
du canada ont rapidement arrêté les deux
jeunes le 14 avril
ils ont ensuite fouillé la résidence des
parents du jeune homme qui venait
d'avoir 18 ans ils ont saisi du matériel
pouvant servir à fabriquer un engin
explosif artisanal un autocuiseur aussi
appelé cocotte-minute semblable à celui
utilisé lors des attentats de boston
ainsi que des clous et du secret mais il
manquait des éléments pour fabriquer la
bombe
la police a aussi découvert que les deux
jeunes venait de louer un appartement
dans hochelaga maisonneuve
ils ont saisi des documents nos sources
nous indiquent que sabrine german et
elle m'a dit jamal y avaient tous deux
signé un bail le 15 mars dernier il
s'était engagé à payer le loyer
jusqu'en juillet 2016 il avait payé le
mois d'avril et le mois de mai en argent
comptant plus de 2000 $ le couple a
raconté à des connaissances qu'il venait
de se marier et voulaient fuir leurs
familles nous avons aussi établi des
liens entre deux jeunes partis à la
mi-janvier pour la turquie et les deux
accusés ils ont tous fréquenté l'école
secondaire georges vanier à montréal
d'ailleurs sabrine german était dans la
même cohorte que l'un des jeunes qu'on
soupçonne d'avoir rejoint le jihad en
syrie son copain elle m'a dit jamal y
avait aussi des liens facebook avec ce
même élève qui entretenait des relations
très étroites avec d'autres jeunes qui
sont partis vers la turquie
à la mi janvier elle m'a dit jamal il
s'est inscrit à une activité facebook en
décembre dernier donnés au centre
communautaire islamique de l'est d'adil
charkaoui l'activité s'intitulait soyons
fiers d'être musulmans
fuyez verra là
et karine depuis l'arrestation du couple
enquête policière a beaucoup progressé
on risque d'en apprendre encore
davantage oui parce qu'il faut
comprendre qu'ils ont été arrêtés la
semaine dernière et s'est écoulé six
jours avant que des accusations
formelles soit portée contre le couple
alors les enquêteurs de la grc ont
rencontré des membres de la famille des
proches des amis des jeunes mais
également ils ont fait des percussions
comme on vient de voir
ils ont effectivement obtenu de la
preuve de la preuve accablante tout ce
qu'ils ont porté ces accusations la qui
sont très sérieuses éventuellement
effectivement on va en apprendre
davantage sur le plan qu'avait ce couple
il va y avoir une suite au pas la
justice demain oui demain ils reviennent
mais c'est une formalité céline
conformant donc au beau fixe une date
pour la procédure et donc on va revenir
devant le tribunal probablement la
semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup dans un prix de numératie
karine